Hi.
My name is Lisa Wray.
And I'm a developer advocate
with the Google Developer
Relations team.
If you're interested
in fitness and you
want to give yourself,
or your users,
more information with just
the device you already
have in your pocket,
you're in the right place.
Today I'm going to talk about
the step sensors available,
starting with Android KitKat.
These step sensors
are hardware sensors
based on the accelerometer.
They're designed to
be low power and won't
burn through your battery.
The step sensors count steps
during walking, running,
and climbing stairs.
And they're smart enough not to
count activities like biking,
driving cars, or
riding in trains.
Android has two sensors
for step counting.
The first is the step detector.
It fires an event when
a step is detected.
One event per step.
The only value it
can return is one.
So if you want to count steps,
you have to do that yourself.
There are two ways to receive
events from the step detector,
continuously or in batches.
If you register your listener
with a maximum delay of zero,
then you'll get
continuous events,
posted as fast as the
sensor can produce them.
The step detector has
a pretty low latency.
So the times at which
you receive step events
should correspond closely
with the user's actual steps.
On the other hand, if you
don't need real-time reporting,
you can allow
events to be batched
by providing a
higher maximum delay.
You'll still get one event
per step but, in this example,
the events could come at as
much as five seconds afterward.
This allows for optimization
at the sensor level.
So be a good Android citizen
and only ask for events
as quickly as you
actually need them.
The step counter is similar to
the step detector in that it
also sends one event per step.
However, the value it sends is
a cumulative number of steps.
The step counter also
takes a little longer
to process the event but it
produces fewer false positives.
So when accuracy is paramount,
use the step counter.
You can also
request these events
as continuous or batched.
So how do we use these sensors?
First, check the device
runs at least Android 4.4
and that it has the
sensors we want.
You can require the
sensors and minimum API
level in the manifest.
Or if your app can work
without the step sensors,
you can check
programmatically for them,
using the package manager.
The simplest way to
use the step sensors
is to listen for steps
only while the app is
running, unregistering
and re-registering
your listeners with
the app lifecycle,
and persisting the previous step
count to add to the new values
reported.
It is also possible to use the
step sensors in the background
when the CPU is suspended.
This requires manually
flushing the sensor event queue
before it overflows.
Speaking of listeners, here's
a sample sensor event listener.
Once you've registered, you get
a callback to on sensor change
every time there's a step event.
We've sum delayed
depending on whether you
requested batched mode.
This listener is
for a step detector.
Here we're implementing
a step counter.
At this point, we can go ahead
and display the step count.
Your listener will be
different, depending
on the type of sensor.
And what you want
to do with the data.
To see this in action, please
download the batched step
sensor sample linked from
the video description
for a full working
example of this code.
And go take it for a walk.
Thanks for watching.